نعم على مدار الليله الماضيه وحتى هذه
اللحظه وتحديدا كانت في الساعات الاولى من
الليله الماضيه كانت الاحزمه الناريه
العنيفه والمجنونه على شرق مخيم جباليا
وشرق جباليا البلد وكذلك في داخل منطقه
جبالي البلد هنالك العديد من المجازي التي
تم ارتكابها عليه الطيارات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه الحربيه هنالك وصل مركز الطبي
في جباليه اكثر من 20 شهيد وعشرات
الاصابات ولكن
هنالك العشرات من الشهداء هم ما زال تحت
بكام وما زالوا في مناطق لا تستطيع سيارات
الاسعاف الوصول الى تلك المنطقه قبل قليل
طائرات الاحتلال وم نوع كواد كابتر وهي
مسيره اسرائيليه اطلقت النيرات تجاه سياره
اسعاف فلسطينيه كانت تتوجه الى المناطق
التي تتعرض التي تعرضت للغارات
الاسرائيليه الاخيره وا طرت الى التراجع
تلك سياره الاستعا وبالتالي هذه
الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه هي نتج عنها
عشرات الشهداء وعشرات الجرحى هؤلاء
الجرحى الان انفجار ضخم ايضا انفجار ضخم
الان في مخيم جباليا في هذه اللحظات
ونتحدث اليكم هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه هي
لم تتوقف للحظه منذ الساعات الاولى من
الليله
الماضيه حزام ناري حزام ناري ايضا في هذه
المنطقه حزام ناري من الغ من الطيرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي تنفذ احزمه
ناريه كثيفه وعنيفه ومجنونه في مخيم
جباليا وفي جباليا البلد هنالك عشرات
الشهداء عشرات الشهداء
وا المئات من الجرحى والمصابين جراء هذه
الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه المتواصله لا
تستطيع سي الاسعاف الوصول الى هذه المناطق
مناطق الاستهدافات والغارات الاسرائيليه
المكثفه كانت اللله الماضيه هي لجله
مجنونه كلمه من الغارات الاسرائيليه
العنيفه والغير مسبوقه في منطقه جغرافيه
صغيره وذات كثافه سكانيه عاليه جدا وهي
منطقه جباليا البلد ومخيم جباليا و هنالك
عده منازل تم استهدافها في هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه
لا تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف الوصول الى تلك
المناطق وعندما حاولت سيارات الاسعاف قبل
قليل التوجه لتلك المناطق اطلق النار
عليها من قبل طائره مسيره اسرائيليه وهذا
هو الحال الان عدد من العمليات التي نسبت
ل الجرحى الفلسطينيين دون غرف عمليات ودون
مستلزمات طبيه وبدون بنج تم تنفيذ هذه
العمليات لانقاذ حياه هؤلاء الجارحى
الفلسطينيين في مركز جباليا الطبي هذا هو
الوضع الحالي هنالك تعج هذا المركز الطبي
بعشرات الجرحى وهو مركز صغير لا
يتسع لهذا العدد الهائل والكبير من الجرحى
الذين يتوافدون كل لحظه الى هذا المركز
الطبي في جبال وبعض النقاط الطبيه الصغيره
التي تنتشر في مدارس الاواء وفي ايضا
لهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ال هذه الحاله
الصعبه الغارات الاسرائيليه هي لم تسكت
وهي مستمره على مدار الساعات الماضيه وحتى
هذه اللحظه والغارات الاسرائيليه مستمره
تقصف في كل مكان تحديدا وبشكل مركز في
جباليا البلد التي تعرضت لمجازر هذه اللله
ولم يتكشف عنها حتى هذه اللحظه بسبب تواجد
بسبب الغارات الاسرائيليه وبسبب الاستهداف
لاي من من لا سياره تتحرك سواء سياره
اسعاف او اي من السيارات التي تحاول
انتشال جرحى او شهداء من تلك المناطق يعني
طول الليل عماد منذ بد هذا القصف الذي
يستهدف جبالي البلد على وجه التحديد لم
يصل اي احد من فرق الاغاثه من المنقذين
الى هذه المواقع
المستهدفه بكل تاكيد هناك مناطق لا تستطيع
سيارات الاسعاف الوصول اليها هناك مناطق
هي تعرضت
ل من الغارات الاسرائيليه العنيفه الليله
الماضيه وفجر اليوم وقبل قليل ايضا ه